we were on new rockstars last week and
today we are gonna do a reaction and
talk about
batman trailer riddler's second clue
solved
new details you missed but before we hop
into this we have an
epic sponsor for today's video huge
thanks to our epic
sponsor epic games what the heck
man i wanted to say it oh
then that was an epic interruption i
just did
nice if you all don't know epic games
they're the purveyors of fortnite and we
don't mean a period of two weeks
i i think they know what we're talking
about but you never know
you can't live your life based on
assumptions
agreed fortnite is literally one of the
most popular cross-platform games
on planet earth and we're especially
excited because season 4 aka
nexus 4 has just launched which sees the
island of fortnite collide
with the greatest heroes and villains
from the canon
of marvel and we don't mean to be filled
with wonder or astonishment
although marvel does provide that
feeling
true which is why nexus war is the
perfect time to jump in
want to smite people with holy
thunderous thor you can
want to cook some fools in dr doom's
domain go right ahead
and it doesn't stop there as the season
progresses even more classic characters
locations and items will be showing up
so if you haven't already you can use
our link in the description box to
download fortnite
for free do it today reject nation
i thought i should change my shirt based
off the subject
totally did not shoot that ad in advance
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the batman trailer shows robert
pattinson
so stumped by ridler's riddles and he's
taking it out on his street fights
stupid my trailer breakdown went into a
pretty insane level of detail with the
many visual clues look at those
views which some of us were able to
solve already but after reviewing it
again this trailer is a
super mysterious enigma with even more
clues to discuss
and no i'm not talking about that
quarterback's mask in the stairwell oh
the mask is the flash of the gunshot
over exposing a normal face sorry to
break your heart
defunct
the riddler's second clue i'm going to
break down all the
stuff i found a spoiler warning because
at this rate i think i'm predicting page
96 of the script we know the answer to
the riddler's first riddle what does a
liar do when he's dead and i explained
how by using a simple substitution
cipher and how only certain consonants
tend to end words repeated like that
you get the hilarious answer of he lies
spill but the important element of that
answer is not the word play
it's the fact that it foretells the
riddler's next target
now this victim here is newly reelected
gotham there don mitchell jr he lies
still is a clue hinting that the next
move will come where this victim's body
lies
still and lies still as the
ah that's clever
fertilized in his eulogy in epitaph but
at this funeral crashes in our next clue
an suv
covered in regular brand duct tape with
the letters d-o-a
question mark driven by a hostage with
another strip of duct tape with no more
lies over his mouth
smartphone apparently in speaker mode
taped to his hand
a yellow clue envelope taped to his
chest and worst of all for him
a bomb strapped to his neck and this
looks familiar
i'm almost certain this is actor peter
sarsgaard who has
oh your favorite
that has and while we never get to see
what is
in that yellow envelope in the trailer
we do hear what i think is at least part
of its contents the voice of paul dano
booms out over the rest of the trailer
[Music]
and it kind of sounds like it's been
electronically filtered through a
speakerphone
so this might be the riddler reading the
riddle back to batman
and yeah if you're a justice please do
not lie
what is the price for your blind eye
rhymes that statement is a
riddle a riddle that i believe is at
least part of riddle number two
so let's dive into it you can interpret
the words here
like what is the price for your blind
eye could be the riddler suggesting
batman and the police have
hypocritically
turned a blind eye to the corruption
within the city's leadership which the
riddler is now trying to expose
and the final exchange of the trailer
sheds more light on that
your target
[Music]
now notice i don't see pattinson's mouth
move in the batcave there
but it sounds like their voices are
still echoing in the cavernous space
suggesting that they could be chatting
over the phone in the cathedral there at
the mayor's funeral
oh one horse director adr
the mystery is going to expose the way
his own role in the city
history of corruption so you start to
see that as it starts to describe
this epic history of corruption in
gotham that you start to understand well
where did my family sit in that the
quarterbacks blind
could be read as a taunt to batman being
blind which was the final riddle answer
of the last time we saw a live action
film riddler
you're as blind as a bat
exactly blind as a bat is actually a
falsity
bats are not blind they see it not as
well as humans do they just nocturnally
use echolocation to track their prey
not because they can only see at night
and not during the day but still it
could be used as a taunt towards batman
for being so focused on nighttime
criminal activity
that he overlooks the city corruption
being committed in broad daylight
yeah there is another interpretation i
think is more telling
i know i know these clues are a bit hard
to find and even harder to decipher
since we're not
in the room with them we're looking
through whatever device you're using to
watch this video and the device you're
probably more accustomed to using for
like
oh say fortnite speaking of which there
it is
there it is now i thought we were the
only ones
i was feeling so honored that fortnite
cared enough about our channel i haven't
seen this kind of ad on
a gazillion other youtuber videos
i didn't reference some of those videos
and there's not a link in our
description box and pin comment as well
choose between them both they're good
seahawk
along with an amnesiac they team up to
fight galactus the bower of the world
hey if we're getting similar ads to new
rock stars hell yeah
yeah we're on the come-up not only have
the marvel heroes and villains landed on
the island but still have their iconic
locations i mean if they can get away
with a marvel ad in a dc video
we can too right you can read the
comments before you choose
nope yes we'll find out shield silver
servers board hey man there's room for
code
in the season channel for free using my
dragon link in the description below
okay really i think the subject of the
second riddle is
lady justice who is often shown
blindfolded to symbolize in particular
you're good senpai
lady justice is an icon of a courtroom
setting
and that first riddler clue was a card
depicting an
owl with a skeleton behind it these two
clues taken together could be even
stronger evidence that the
court of owls are behind all of this the
court of owls is the secret cabal of
leaders running gotham for centuries
and now the riddler could be exposing
the skeletons in the closets of the owls
by killing off the city leaders that
they
corruptly put in power looking back at
that first riddle it's also interesting
how its cover contained a word with an
extra
o to make a double entendre like an owl
hoot
and the second riddle does the same
thing the car
of the district attorney is marked d-o-a
it inserts an extra o
in the middle of the letters d and a
making the d a the district attorney
doa dead on arrival so what is the exact
answer for riddle number two
what is the price the riddler is asking
about is it corruption
is it the court of owls i think those
answers are too general the real answer
is likely to be another dark pun
or a turn of phrase that tells us
something about the riddler's next
target
lady justice is blinded yet carries a
sword
that sword symbolizes the swift blow of
justice
the executioner sword and the common
critique of justice being blind is that
it could be blind to the truth that
innocent people have historically lost
their heads in the name of justice
so while we don't know yet what exactly
is written inside that envelope going
off the sentence structure riddle number
one i'm willing to bet that the
inscription is something like
what does justice get when she's blind
the answer
she gets ahead and that head
because the next target the riddler
believes is a just
execution a particularly savage murder
police commissioner peter savage
beheaded
important to take his place look we know
this riddler is
knowledgeable he just learned that his
mask is modeled on the us military
extreme cold weather mask
which along with its coat are things
that you can get from an army surplus
store
meaning edward nashton is a practical
killer who ain't afraid to get bloody
this could also explain another new
detail we spotted from the trailer
the moment batman scuffles with the
other gcpd cops in the police station
during that scuffle if you look closely
there is a stretcher on the table
and batman's arms appear to be cuffed
behind his back
i think we may be looking at the
aftermath of that funeral bombing
which caught batman in the class but
afterward the police commissioner was
found
beheaded in the cops already so he did
go
somewhere to get us now looking for
someone
commissioner cuff batman while he is
incapacitated
and so like great batman detective
comics like the long halloween hush
gotham by gaslight batman is going to
have to apply
actual detective work to sleuth out the
truth in order to prove his own rights
something that might be pretty hard for
bruce to do since i think we are also
likely to learn about his parents
involvement with the court of owls
in fact on the same process he'll be
exploring those detectors
to evaluate how great of a detective
batman actually is and whether he's
worthy of the title of the world's
greatest detective
keep an eye out for it not a blind one
to join us as we try to break this nerdy
mystery in our downtime join new
rockstar's official discord server which
you can access by becoming a patron at
any tier
at patreon.com even at a dollar follow
me on instagram
ea boss follow me rockstars subscribe
and hit that notification bell for the
latest deep dives into everything you
care about thanks for watching batman
batman thanks for watching batman
at this point in time it's an
appropriate button for anything batman
so before all these videos eric usually
says
spoil the warning in case any of my
predictions are correct
and while we haven't been reacting to
the other ones i have seen
some of the other ones especially in
regards to the batman i feel like that
spoiler warning is necessary
yes you know every once in a while any
channel that does
like a deep dive into possible easter
eggs or trying to
figure out the plot a lot of times
you're like might be a little
far-fetched might be a little too
far-fetched you're throwing whatever at
the wall
but the more he dissects these
the more i'm like is matt reeves going
to watch this and go we should change
our script
because we'll talk about that exact
response because there is so much
response both in just enthusiasm in
people's opinions but also people
breaking it down
like they could very well use this to
get ahead of themselves
i mean it's hard to debunk or be like i
don't know about that eric
i don't know about that you know this
was among the most compelling breakdowns
i've ever seen of yours because i was
sitting there going wow
with the amount of like things you're
being able to grab out of the frame to
support these theories plus
just the extrapolations in theme with
the tones that the trailer does
give us it really does seem like you're
on the right track we were just on new
rockstars rogue theory we talked about
suicide squad but the main topic the
first one was us discussing the batman
real villain riddler court of owls
hush john talked about like how he
thinks uh hugo strange might be
the one involved in the next batman
movie i talk about how i think this is
all linked to the court of owls a little
competition i really think you guys
would appreciate that if you're enjoying
any of these like batman videos and
whatnot i think you guys
really love checking that one out where
we really dive into a lot of the court
of owl speculation as well but
everything that we were getting here of
things i hadn't uh
considered especially i don't take any
time to try to solve the riddler's
clues i suck at basic riddles i do i'm
terrible at those things sometimes i
heard you chuckling and be like
and i'm like i don't get it i need you
to expositionally explain this to me
yeah
that's okay that's why i'm here i mean
first off that actor has to be peter
sarsgaard it just looks somewhat even in
the first time i saw the trailer i was
like the top of that guy's head looks so
familiar
yeah i kept looking at it too going who
is this guy yeah yeah and then he once
you set peter sarsgaard i was like
whoa that's definitely peter's yard
district attorney like it just all signs
point so well to there
and if you've been watching this channel
for a while you'll know that i
unfairly
for some reason irrationally just do not
click with peterson
cyber bully peterson whatever grace
randolph feels
with jessica chastain i feel it for
peter sarsgaard the funny thing is
he's in green lantern as hector hammond
yet i thought he was the best part of
that movie
so turning point is as much as hated as
that movie is i was like well you know
what the actor who i really don't like
i thought he was the best part um but
this the play on words especially with
the double
o's like what do those extra o's mean i
would have never picked up on that
though those clues especially uh i love
the like the double meanings and the
playing words like he lies still
i know other people have decoded that
already for the heli still the double
meaning there
the doa dead on arrival taking apart the
district attorney and adding the owen
there i think is a brilliant turn
what i'm loving about from all these
breakdowns that we've been getting
of the riddler what his possible
portrayal might be like
and i said this in the rogue theory
video he really does seem like a cross
between kevin spacey from seven
robin williams from the movie insomnia a
guy who might know who batman really is
yet at the same time doesn't see himself
as a villain at
all like he he acts in a way that is
trying to expose the law
as if the lies really bother him yeah
and he
like he's doing these violent pure
criminal acts
he does it in the name of what he
believes to really be the true
justice in terms of like a movie that
explores the soul of
batman you know how far apart are they
really what really separates these two
between batman like just because he
doesn't kill is that the only thing that
separates him are they gonna go down
that angle in matt reeves version
yeah i'm just looking forward to seeing
whatever duality complexities they
they strike between hero and main
villain in this movie
yeah and the juxtaposition of you know
street level crime versus you know
societal crime and things like that yes
and i love that connection to the lady
liberty as well and the whole idea of
justice lady justice listen listen
or read notes that i wrote
juice dice with the yeah like the whole
i don't know exactly what's gonna be in
that envelope but that seems like a very
uh solid guess especially you know i i
love that it's easy to mislead with
batman and any good
riddle will mislead you as well i'm
excited for the riddler because too
again like a good riddle is hard to
write but if eric is figuring these out
and especially if he's figuring it out
ahead
of time
that's why i put an extra emphasis on
the ahead
c is so good i i missed it the first
time it's
triple meaning because i'm saying he's
figuring out in advance and then it's
referencing the head thing that he said
in the video
this is our contribution to eric's
intense breakdown
right for all your hours of solving and
cracking we got jokes yeah the
commissioner either has to retire at
some point or be
killed off i feel like we're going to
see so many funerals in this movie well
yeah because it seems like part of maybe
the game will be and this is what is
starting to really uh clear the vision
of seven for me is yeah
a a body with a riddle attached to it
that seems to be the pattern
like if he's figuring out that clue to
advance of like gets a head
whatever eric was talking about there
and then for the commissioner to have
his head blown off i didn't pick up
on batman possibly being handcuffed to
me i just chalked it up to oh it's the
batsuit it's got a little bit of a stiff
surface yeah you want to be able to turn
your head
this has got all that armor plating it's
not very mobile but
then again when looking at the badass
scene where he beats that one guy down
his shoulders don't look stiff
he's swift yeah exactly so yeah he must
be handcuffed there it's just funny how
previous batman costume
knowledge played into my subconscious
mindset and seeing that scene with the
cops i love the concept of
really the gcpd viewing him as a
criminal him having to
on top of that maybe it's like maybe
it's not the main plot like the act 2
plot but
the midpoint plot when the film takes a
turn him having to work to prove his
innocence
yeah and that's maybe why something has
to leave with him teaming up with
catwoman you know yeah
he can't work with the gcpd anymore he
can't work with the commissioner
so maybe he needs the help of catwoman
it's possible
we added something boom
well and even and like i liked even just
seeing that scene where he's walking
down the hall behind commissioner gordon
again
through this new lens of oh maybe this
is after a really awkward confrontation
with the cops
yeah yeah and now everyone's like hey
bats don't like you
i guess we need your help well this is
great this reacted in new rockstars
videos
i also want to say thank you to nr for
bringing us on again we
really love doing rogue theory yeah and
eric voss
is a very very sw whatever impression
you get from him
on the videos and granted we've only you
know conversed with him
off recording on the zoom yeah so
maybe so he could totally maybe eric
lost his total church
the second we leave that call he's like
oh those guys from
the conversations we have had with the
gentleman he is
just that a gentleman and he's very very
funny there's so many things
that like he'll be improvising or joking
around about in conversation or
things that are don't go up in the video
that we're just having us crack up he is
a hilarious dude yeah
and uh lives up to the hype he really
does man he really does can't wait to
meet him in person one day
all right he just starts running around
breakdown subscribe to new rockstars
thank you to epic games make sure to go
check out the link in the description
box fortnight
season 4 nexus war marvel
our link not not eric's not eric's
[Music]